Lily Gottfried is here the the the
daughter of the late great Gilbert
Godfrey to friend of ours uh who uh has
made a short film right the hidden
talent of Gilbert Gottfried available
today on YouTube or by going to Gilbert
godfreed.com
yeah I did
um I made a short documentary about my
father because no one knew he was
actually like a really talented artist
and I wanted like his fans and other
people to be inspired by that and know
that you can be creative in more than
one way it's weird too I never knew that
he had any type of art like I didn't
know he drew or did any of that stuff
um were you surprised with how people
saw your dad compared to how he really
was a hundred percent like out on the
stage he was very different to how I
knew him personally he was like this
sweet dad at home he was very like shy
and quiet but the minute he got out on
stage he was like this like super loud
guy like you would never know that was
the funny part too I've seen with the
Comedy Cellar and he beat the table just
very quiet having a wine and you go hey
oh hi he was just such a different
person
um but I didn't know he had artistic
ability at all and the stuff you showed
is so interesting yeah but it seems like
that's exactly what Gilbert would have
drawn yeah it's really beautiful like
it's a way to like see
inside of his mind and like see all of
his thoughts like written on paper are
you like him at all or is your brother
like him
um my brother definitely has his more
like outgoing personality I feel like I
kind of have like more of a shy
personality but once you get to know me
I kind of open up more and I think
that's with him also yeah I think I even
I think your dad seemed like he was kind
of shy when he was we had like a Persona
right like he was very outgoing with his
persona but the real person was a
totally different entity yeah yeah I've
taken like little shuttles to hotels and
stuff with him and he was never loud in
the car but then it's like you're on
stage he's like who's this monster
it took a completely different how old
were you when you got to see his his
comedy and got more acquainted with the
way so much of the world knew him I
don't know really what age but I feel
like I kind of like when I was
definitely like very young I would like
walk with him on the street and fans
would come up to us and I would be like
how are you friends with everyone like I
thought they were all his friends
friends like I wasn't very like open to
it but I guess like as I got older and
matured like my mom would let me come to
like some of his comedy shows but I
could only watch it for five minutes
until the set got dirty she like had to
cover my ears yeah yeah and then it is
funny though it's like I know that he'll
be okay for five minutes and then it
just once it starts going down it's
gonna keep going and going and going now
do you have any uh because obviously you
you kind of you put this together this
was your idea to do this yeah yeah
um was it something that you always
thought of like hey somebody should talk
about this or was it after that he he
passed away you're like you know what I
want people to know this I like never
really thought about it before until he
passed away honestly but like in school
we had like a project to create a
documentary and that was like
automatically the first thing that I
thought of in my mind I don't know how
honestly because I never thought of it
before had you ever thought of doing
documentaries about anything before or
producing things
um producing things yes but I never
really thought I would make a
documentary and how did you like doing
it
um in the beginning I didn't really like
it because there was so much information
I had to tell and it took like a while
to put everything together I had to redo
it like three times it was a lot of
effort and I was like about to quit but
like my mom like convinced me that this
is like a good idea like this is like
about your dad like all of his fans are
gonna like it and that like convinced me
more and in the end I'm so happy that I
did it yeah it's really interesting with
him too I feel like there was like
his fans were so rapidly fans of his but
also
when people got to know him a little bit
more like documentary that came out
right that kind of explained who he was
more as a person he got to see his home
life you got to see him stealing bottles
of shampoo from hotels like you got to
see all this other stuff that you never
got from him on stage it seemed like
people just ate that up so it's not
surprising that people are still
fascinated by all these different parts
of who this person was yeah like there's
so much more of him that you can learn
and I think the documentary like the art
documentary but also like his like
documentary about his life gave so much
more of an insight to like his home life
and who he was like to his family and by
and to congratulations too you won
um I'm really getting old and blind uh
it's an eight minute short and uh you
won the silver medal at the New York
Alliance film festival and you want and
again an honorable mention at the
student World impact Film Festival
that's gonna feel great to like this the
first thing you do it's about something
so important to you and people are like
really recognizing it as good well I'm
really really glad like people like it
like I feel like that like kind of shows
it also so that makes me happy what did
you redo about like what was something
you did the first time like I didn't
like how that came out
um
what made it hard was that I had to put
all the information in one like place
kind of and it was very like complicated
because there was so much stuff I had to
put in and like
when I finally like sat down and wrote
it all out like wrote a storyline and
everything and made it easier but at
first it was just very complicated like
there was a lot of things in my head and
you I guess you run out everything you
were gonna say and then you said okay
I'm gonna show this then uh did you
decide did you write up the script first
or did you like line up all the shots
first and go okay I'll do this in
Reverse um I wrote the script first but
what made it hard at first was I kind of
put in all the pictures and everything
and then it made it more confusing
because I didn't know what I was gonna
say for each right yeah he's got a bunch
of you have to talk about one and then
all of a sudden it moves and then you're
like you're still talking about it the
next one yeah I would I would have done
a terrible job you think so yeah I would
have sucked I mean this is actually
really good I saw it
um your mom sent it to me it was it was
actually like this is actually very good
not that I didn't think it would be good
but you never know what something's
going to be but it was very easy to
watch I was like I wish it was a little
longer like which is nice are you
allowed to uh
go on YouTube and and search for your
dad's like uh
material radio Rants and stuff like that
because this I mean something that I
feel like he became really known for is
just the roles right the roles that he
would go on if there was not when
Gilbert was in studio it was like once
the joke started there was nothing and
he was on fire coming up with another
punch line and another punch line and
another punch line I mean the best I
like really respected that about him
like I wish I had I like could do that
but I I guess I have like other ways
yeah you I mean you know your dad was a
very unique thinker
just shouting the most offensive
punchline
yeah you actually could do that if you
just stood in the subway and screamed at
people yeah
are you creative in any other like like
where does your brother did either one
of you want to be performers or or have
a comedy desire or or acting or anything
like that
um my brother like I think he wanted to
like go to MIT for a I can't when he was
like seven and then he wanted to do
something with video games but honestly
I think he could be like a really good
performer because he's very outgoing and
for me personally I definitely want to
work like somewhere in the film industry
do you know what you want to do like do
you do you want to be in front of the
camera or behind it like both I'm not
sure because I could take acting classes
and get better at that or like for my
whole life I've always liked to like
film stuff and direct so you've been
filming stuff since you were like really
young yeah yeah and you're in high
school now yeah yeah so what is what is
next for you like you you're gonna
finish school in a few years and then
like what do you want to do after that
do you want to go to college or do you
want to just start working yeah I want
to go to college so definitely some
place that like has a good like film
place right like NYU or something you
know in high school Coop used to
photoshop his report cards his parents
didn't know he was about to fail high
school we just found that out before you
walked in did you ever photoshop your
report cards no yeah okay now you
actually just did well no yeah yeah yeah
he also his parents sent him to the
slums of California for a year Oakland
yeah because they didn't trust him to go
to college oh so I'm like what you're
doing now if you're not giving yourself
enough credit understand like that that
you are so far above the bar from what
we're used to with people your age it's
pretty remarkable you know so congrats
congrats thank you also we should
mention that uh the film is free but you
can donate uh to I'm gonna make sure I
say this right the Gilbert Gottfried uh
myotonic dystrophy type 2 research fund
is that correct uh the hiddentalent.org
so if you want to you know uh help a
cause that you know obviously affects a
lot of people
um and it's got to feel good like when
when something sad happens or we're
grieving like to be able to do something
creative to kind of make sense out of it
I mean that's a really good thing I mean
it was definitely my way to like I guess
cope with it and understand him more but
I also really wanted like other people
to see that he had all these other
talents does your brain work the way his
worked at all like either not
necessarily on stage but as a person off
stage yeah I think 100 like
um he was sometimes like a very person
very hard person to talk to like I
couldn't have like very like honest like
World conversations about him but I feel
like it was kind of like this
subconscious thing that I kind of felt
like we connected very well well I mean
he had a genius brain and it just genius
brains work strange they're not as you
know what I mean they're not okay
they're not amazing at this but like at
that you know like there's probably
nothing you could have told him that he
would have thought was crazy either yeah
so that you know there's the your mom is
the stable like you know let's be honest
you know I mean every family there's the
stable one and then there's the other
one and yeah did he ever do his Alan
Thicke impression at home
maybe like one time I might have heard
it when they were doing like the podcast
at home yeah yeah it was one of my
favorites the Allen think he did
Celebrity Wife yes he did yeah
thanks uh significant other and he she
didn't like that he kept doing the Alan
Thick impression to her she found it
insulting I I mean I like was there when
they were filming it so I probably heard
it when he was at home did you know that
if your dad found something that uh that
was annoying other people that he would
gladly do it over and over just to kind
of yeah yeah
and I I like had that personal
experience at home what would annoy you
that he that he might do was there
somebody a phrase or was it something he
would
um I don't remember but I
I just remember the fact that
said a phrase We would say like again
again and then he would just say it over
and over again until it annoyed my mom
so much yeah which was probably after
twice
but as kids kids love redundancy so when
you're a kid over and over there's never
too many times when you're young never
yeah plus there's also that thing of he
would do it so many times
that it's like it's not funny anymore
but he keeps doing it until okay it's
funny it's funny again yeah there's a
shelf life where it dies but then it
comes back right he just plowed right
through which was great yeah now are are
you uh are you good in school or is this
like the the best thing you're doing or
or is it not your thing
um like it's been a hard
from Florida back to New York and I'm
going to like a new school and
everything so my grades this year
definitely weren't at like its peak but
I feel like this was kind of a way to
like show my abilities more
but they weren't like I have to
photoshop my report card back no no I
just want to make sure yeah yeah do you
miss I need probably miss your friends
but do you miss Florida or do you prefer
New York
um
I like New York work and like the whole
like City life and everything but it's
definitely been like a harder year than
last year and I do miss like my friends
from Florida and I liked like being able
to just like open the door and walk
outside how hard is it at 16 to make new
friends like when you move to a new
place I mean that's got to be a
nightmare yeah Jim was just saying
yesterday you can't make any 16 year old
friends I know I'm on Tick Tock I do
funny dances they go you fat boomer
but if you're yeah it just seems
impossible like I moved once or twice
when I was a kid and then never again
but it just it always sucks going to a
new school and meeting new people yeah
it's definitely hard because last year I
feel like it was kind of easy I was
going into ninth grade and like kind of
everyone was new so I found like my crew
pretty easily but going to a new school
where everyone's been there for like
years and they all known each other for
years it's definitely hard
can I ask your opinion as a 16 year old
this is a conversation that has been
happening around here lately uh Troy is
uh well he's going through like a late
midlife crisis
and he's been in like he's found new pop
music you know and he's coming up with
all these ridiculous opinions
um music that is really designed for
young people and he's been running
around here insisting that Zayn is the
number two in One Direction
and to Travis and I this sounds
ridiculous right like it's clearly Nile
but Troy is like up and down insisting
it's Zayn can I mean you seem like you'd
probably be the authority on this more
than any of us
um I think I prefer Zayn
here we go oh wow she knows what's
up that's that's real strong that's real
stratified all right unpopular opinion
but oh that's oh that's unpopular though
I I don't know I don't listen to One
Direction that much but I do know enough
to say that it's sane do you not like
them because they're a little too
childish
I don't know be like Harry Styles
no
whoa
I don't I don't hate him no no no no
right right it's just he's who do you
who are you listening to uh
older music because you're cool yeah and
also probably because you grew up with
all these older influent like older
movies you watch older movies did your
father ever make you like or ask you to
watch all the films I I watched like a
lot of monster old movies old Abbott and
Costello oh Lon Chaney stuff yes yes it
is funny right like somebody's someone
who's like 40 might not have seen a lot
of those things but because your dad he
just kind of like loved everything
before 1980. yeah yeah I liked growing
up with that like having that experience
and and like seeing all these like
movies and like hearing about all these
like like artists and stuff like I have
a record player and I like went to a
store and I just bought like all these
like old records do you still like old
movies or are you kind of done with them
old movies not really but I can't I
stuck with them the music
which is like what what music
like I listened
listened Radiohead which isn't really
that
I like it
I mean people realize yeah you know it
is you know yeah a lot of like beetles
and stuff and then I like
in the records I got they're definitely
like way too old for me to know but my
mom listened to a lot of the music so
she's gonna like put me on to that is it
crazy how the Beatles like I I can't
think of any band that like uh
generationally like just works for every
every group of young people like I'm
sure that is up they're Timeless they
really hold up like other people in your
age group like them or they look at you
like what are you listening to No I
think a lot of people definitely like
yeah yeah it's crazy like I can't think
of anyone else that Bob Marley seems to
cross over like every race I Bob Marley
kind of equally crosses over in the
Beatles it's with the with the age I
also think that especially now there's
so much more exposure to older music
where you can find it like when we were
growing up like you wouldn't go and buy
a CD
of like an older band but if it were
just online right if we're just on
Spotify or YouTube I guess it might be
easier to find it like it's easier to
find like Radiohead even though it's 30
years old then whatever when we were
growing up and you know stuff in the 60s
I'm not gonna go buy The Mamas and the
Papas I just bought them did you really
yeah
you want on Spotify uh I got her I got
like their album you bought a record
yeah a stupid question of course you did
and you really like it yeah I I haven't
listened to it on like my record player
but yeah do you like the sound because
there's this whole thing now with
records where people like I like the
full Rich sound do you see a difference
between that and listening on your phone
yeah it's more like clear I feel like
it's more like
fake kind of like two like perfect I
guess when it's on your phone I feel
like on a record it kind of gives it
more of that like scratchy like richer
feeling yeah that that feel that little
crackle yeah there's a little crackle
that happens on a record which I hated
because I grew up with it there's
something tangible about it I guess so
yeah and it does have a nice rich sound
right but I mean once I got like digital
music I'll never go back yeah yeah
because once you start having albums
skip any of your records skip where they
just keep playing the same thing over
and over drives you crazy
if it does
this moment if it happens and you're
going yeah your records suck records
um I also no do you have any more
festivals that you're entering this in
or like what happens with this now
because it's obviously gotten such a
good response um I applied to a bunch so
I guess we'll see what happens oh you
have to send it out and see if they're
going to are you nervous watching it in
front because I hate watching anything I
do and so does everybody else but I hate
watching that in front of people
um it's a little bit scary scary but I
guess like through my experiences so far
like being at a film festival I kind of
imagine myself as the audience watching
it instead of like that I like made this
film and it makes it easier
right because you're just kind of
narrating something it's not like you're
you're jokes or your paintings or your
pictures it's just you're just telling
somebody about somebody else you're it's
by the way as we said earlier it's
available on uh on YouTube uh right now
if you want to check it out on Gilbert
Godfrey's YouTube channel
um I know that you also helped him
with his social media
which could not have been an easy task
uh because Jim I'm sure you remember
that we he was on Zoom with us a few
times during the pandemic but there was
there was one time where you guys left
him alone to get on Zoom with us and I
mean the whole show we're on live the
whole show was just Gilbert fumbling
with his Zoom cameras trying to figure
out how to get connected and us watching
him going like no you're on you're on
you're on what do we what no I think
what do we I don't I don't see you and
then your mom would come in and fix it
oh okay here we go yeah it couldn't have
been the easiest process to get him
involved with technology
um he wasn't good at good at technology
which I I kind of told him what to do
and filmed everything and made all the
ideas so
like I think his fans definitely liked
it because it was a lot of more like
modern humor that was popular like on
Tick Tock at the time like I got him
almost like a million followers and
really a ton of likes so he was
definitely like it was very fun for me
yeah to do his social media yeah yeah
it's got to be like we talked about this
before you came in like we're all older
so we didn't grow up with social media
so much older than others yeah I would
be the oldest person in there
um but he looks older he looks just
horrible for him
um growing up with social media like are
you like because everybody gets into are
you afraid of like what jokes you might
make or are you really careful about
everything you write because you see
what happens
yes and no I feel like I could be more
careful but in terms of like some of the
stuff I put out I feel like I have like
a good judgment but you're not gonna say
anything stupid no do you watch what
your friends are doing and go like oh
their life's gonna be ruined in a week
teens getting canceled
right like I'll see sometimes a person
make a joke and I'm like oh
there is oh yeah and you and you're on
Tick Tock yeah do you uh what do you
what do you post do you post jokes do
you post real life conspiracy theories
um not really truths
I guess just like my life on Tick Tock
but
um for my dad I had definitely more of
like the comedy like I feel like I could
post I no honestly I feel like I could
never post like comedy stuff because it
was his whole like personality and like
who people knew him as so it was so much
easier to make videos for him yeah yeah
and it's and it's great to get his
content out to an entirely New
Generation in this way that people are
consuming content is incredible but it's
also like it's Gotta Be Wild for you
because like Disney cartoons last
forever like every like when you're
every kid still grows up with Disney
cartoons I'll show my kids the same
cartoons that I watched so like when you
realize that your dad's the parrot in
Aladdin that's not a typical thing for a
child to grow up with but had to be a
wild experience I've watched the movie a
lot when I was younger yeah but I feel
like I never really thought that much of
it because he's not screaming like a
parrot around the house yeah yeah were
you able to make that connection like
you knew it was him but would you hear
that and go that's dad or would it just
be kind of part of the movie part of the
movie yeah it wasn't until I like grew
up more and like until people would come
up to me and say like oh my God that's
your dad like he was like my entire
childhood and then it kind of like
clicked you ever see Problem Child yes
yeah yeah I don't think is that Macaulay
Culkin no no no no no that's uh John
Ritter and I don't know what the kid's
name was he was mainly famous for
Problem Child but uh yeah it's great
Gilbert plays the principal do you do
you like to see two like you your dad
gets so many nice tributes and nobody
has a bad thing to say about him like
very rare for comedians like for no one
to have a bad thing to say but no one
has anything negative to say about your
your father like that's got to make you
feel good if you see all these nice
tributes and peop the kind of the uh the
uh uh respect people have for your
father yeah it makes me really happy it
does yeah and I feel like well he's
definitely made like a lot of
controversial jokes over the years but
but in
in the end people think he's like even
funnier so there was a commitment he had
to it and there was an odd like he was a
very smart guy but there was almost the
innocence of it was that you knew he
really was just trying to be funny like
even people who got pissed off at him no
one ever thought he was trying to be
hurtful like he would just say these
things that people would be like oh but
you just knew like that all right I
guess that one missed but everyone I
think knew that his intention wasn't to
be hurtful yeah like he would kind of
like go and do his shows and I think
there was this one time that he made
like an offensive joke on stage and
people were booing him and then he was
like okay well this can't get any worse
so he made an even worse job
and then and then like the whole crowd
laughed yeah because he literally gives
you the choice like this is how this is
gonna go yes yeah I'm acknowledging that
you don't like this yeah it can get
worse like he doesn't really care what
other people think and I like respected
that about honestly yeah it's so great
and if he did carry hit it better than
anyone I've ever seen because if they're
bullying you for something you say
that's offensive he basically gave them
a choice like yeah you're gonna continue
to boot and I'm gonna get worse and
worse or you're just going to realize
we're going to have a good time a great
way to handle it because he almost
couldn't be offensive the worse he got
as he would go on like the Sam said
those roles you'd be like it's not
offensive it's such a ridiculous thing
you know that he doesn't mean it was his
uh reluctancy to spend money and uh
search of value in terms of strictly
money his cheapness was it ever uh was
never embarrassing on like family trips
or anything uh
people kind of had that impression like
growing up he would always take me to
the dollar store and we would like pick
out little toys together
can you imagine it was definitely it was
definitely a bondage
[Laughter]
so would there be times when you guys
were out your mom would have to go look
no we can't we have to yeah what a move
though
good boy story yeah let's go to the Toy
Story it's the dollar store my my mom is
down to earth but she definitely isn't
that level of cheap
that's a very uh yeah that's a very a
great summary you're very comfortable
too because I watched one of your
interviews that you your your mom sent
me on when you did some new show you
seem very comfortable talking and and
being in front of people and And
discussing something uh is that
something that kind of clicked quickly
once this came out or did you kind of
always have that I feel like I
[Music]
kind of like natural for me I guess I
guess like I was definitely
like the camera
like turned on I was like fine and
comfortable when I was younger I was
definitely more shy like in front of the
camera and stuff but I feel like it got
better
plus you guys did TV already yeah yeah I
like grew up with it and you did uh what
was it the tournament of laughs you guys
were all in that guest with your thought
which was fun
I guess yeah I made up some of the ideas
did you really yeah and he just kind of
went with it yeah that's awesome yeah I
mean that's that's nice far more
wholesome than your tournament of laughs
yeah
um
and have you met most of your dad's
friends yeah
yeah he loved your dad and Penn Gillette
pendula yeah
yeah movie so oh that's right yeah he
did but did he I don't know what he did
but I did he just did like a we just had
like a little
talked a little bit about my dad because
he knew his artwork oh he was aware of
it before yeah yeah so is this something
that you wanted what else would you do a
documentary on if like this obviously is
doing very well and people are probably
going to say hey do you want to do
anything else what subject would you
want to do
um I feel like his documentary like his
like personal documentary on his life
definitely had like a lot of like
personal information about him but I
feel like I could go like a little bit
more in depth about my experience oh
okay she asked his kid yeah plus you're
older than when the documentary came out
so you're you're like you probably have
a grasp on what you'd want to say yeah
yeah higher perspective of like normal
home life right this kind of essence
being the patriarch of the home that's
that's interesting I agree yeah well
look Lily I mean it's really let's give
the proper plug here
um I want to make sure again I'm a
half-blindful let me see I was gonna say
when you were like I'm gonna give the
proper plug I know and I I realize my
arms don't go out any further stupid fat
old man
oh wait okay uh let me plug this uh the
family is also selling they're selling
limited edition Prince of Gilbert's
original artwork on the website now
they're limited to only 300 copies and
it does have a certificate of
authenticity uh signed by Dara who is of
course Gilbert's wife and uh there's
three different pieces Chico needed the
money fishing and molari curly they were
created when he was a teenager wow a
teenager in the 70s and were discovered
by Dara when they started dating in 1990
can we jump grab you for one second
um
uh uh you and Gilbert
started dating in the in in the 90s how
did you find his artwork did he show it
to you as like something he was proud of
no no
no I was in his bedroom helping him
because it was a disaster and looked
under his bed which was absolutely
disgusting and I found them stored under
his bed how did you guys meet
we met at a Grammy party a Tavern on the
Green when the Grammys were in New York
in 97. February 26 1997. and you
explained the story explain the story
yeah thank you maybe you could be an
interviewer
[Laughter]
um by the way great job Lily I'm very
proud of you
um I was at the food table and Gilbert
was invited to the party because he
would go anywhere where there was free
food so we were in line and I dropped
the food that they gave me and he picked
it up and put it on his plate
and I looked at him and I thought oh my
God who is this weird guy putting my
dropped crap food on his plate and he
looked lost and he said he was meeting
his friends there and he didn't know
where they were yet so he came and sat
at my table was that a line or was he
actually waiting for friends he was
waiting for friends okay yeah he's the
first man in history to ever meet a
woman by picking up her dropped food
happen that's how you know and what was
it about him that you did you just did
you like the way his brain worked when
you first met him or did you like this
guy is extremely interesting
um to he I met him and um
he was he had this like
soft sweet innocent kind of look to him
like puppy dog kind of look like I kind
of felt bad for him
um but he was sweet and then he hit the
first date he asked me out two days
later and I thought oh this older man's
asking me out and blah blah blah and I
really didn't know much about him at all
um and he asked me out I got all dressed
up and he asked me out and it was the
Moonstruck Diner on 23rd Street and we
sat down and we split one rice pudding
he was too cheap
[Laughter]
I guess there's something romantic about
splitting a rice pudding and then he
watches it was very sweet he walked me
home and he told me like an hour of
turtle jokes
squid and turtle judgment thought this
is the most bizarre date I was just it
was refreshing it was refreshing to have
someone that didn't care about social
norms that was so odd and different but
sweet and funny and but imagine his
perspective when you found somebody that
will put up with you splitting a dessert
and then telling an hour of turtle jokes
yeah he hit the lottery yeah he hit the
lotto now Lily when you're growing up
who who was the the disciplinarian in
the house like if you were if you
screwed up who are you more worried
about my mom 100 oh yeah my dad never
got me he didn't well
one time if there was a build up of like
my brother fighting he would like get
mad like I've probably seen him like
scream and get mad probably two times in
my life wow he didn't he was always my
mom
but he didn't seem like a guy who would
hold the grudge like he didn't seem like
a guy if he was angry that would stay
angry for a week you seemed like I gotta
kind of Let It Go quickly yeah he does
yeah we never fought you didn't right
never had a fight wow never fun if you
had conflict would you just would you be
comfortable just talking it out or how
did you deal with it he wouldn't talk it
out I would talk it out and then we
would make a joke and laugh okay but was
he a good listener
yeah yeah was he that listen yeah yeah
listen yeah he didn't say as much but he
listened no he he doesn't understand but
what about the time what about the time
that he forgot that he had a kid no oh
no
when Lily was first born I was at the
gym and I called him because he was she
was napping and I called him I said
how's it going and he's like what do you
mean I said how's it going are you at
home you know how's it going Lilly's
napping he's like oh
I left the house I forgot I forgot he
left
he's like I'll be right home I'll be
right home
one time like I said make sure make sure
she goes to sleep blah blah blah and I
go out and I came home and you're like
you know three years old whatever up at
like 11 o'clock eating potato chips on
the couch with it or the time that he
you were crying you know about this
story maybe you were crying and he just
was like just go to sleep go to sleep
and finally he went and he went to check
on you and and I guess he had dropped
his glasses in your pajamas and your
onesies yes they were in in the leg of
your pajamas
he probably they probably were they were
on there he probably didn't notice it
put them on and just sent you the bed
you're all over
oh yeah he was watching TV and she was
sitting on his lap and he wasn't paying
attention and she took a pen and Drew
all over herself and he had no clue he
was watching TV the whole time did he
area was he by the way that moment of
realization that's the beauty of it when
like your wife gets home and goes like
she's sitting on your lap and she's
drawing all over her legs and you as the
guy have to go oh yeah
she is oh uh so was he would you like
would he give you advice about things or
was he more like you would just listen
to a problem or
um like if there was something you
wanted to know would you be more likely
to go to him or your mom
um like about what anything in life in
school you're having a problem with
somebody or you had a crush on somebody
or you didn't understand something uh
you know a problem
um
I would go to my mom for like the
realistic information and I would go
from to my dad for like the jokey kind
of like funny I just want to hear what
he'll say to this yeah
well the things he did help you with
like when you were studying you read you
read Frankenstein oh yeah he helped me
really excited he was really excited
about that was that required reading in
school that's when you like submitted
200-page book report that was supposed
to be three tickets gave you way too
much information it was in like
had to read it out loud during class so
it was fun
fun was it funny or was it just really
really thorough
thorough it was thorough did you like
the book complicated it was really
complicated to read yeah it seems like
it right I don't think I've ever read it
I mean I've seen the film but I've never
actually read the book did you like the
book or ultimately not like it uh uh
half and half
yeah I guess it's kind of cool cause
it's a monster but if you're forced to
read anything you're forced to read yeah
it's a monster but it's still a book
yeah exactly yeah that's kind of it I
mean like Dracula is interesting but you
don't want to be forced to read about it
um what would you like people to learn
from this uh like if you could pick one
thing that people would walk away
knowing about your dad
hmm
probably that like he had like people
always have like two sides of them
like you could be like this one like
really outgoing person but I also have
this like sort of shy and sweet side to
you so I guess like that like with every
person you're gonna find like multiple
things about them that you didn't know
from before and I guess like don't have
this like super like
like strong first impression on someone
right because there's definitely more
you can learn about people you're seeing
one side of them and uh yeah there's a
whole other part that most people don't
see and I guess as we uh I guess our
show is ending soon but you're going to
uh Europe I think your mom said yeah oh
that's nice what are you gonna do there
I'm going on a teen Tour de France Italy
and Switzerland oh awesome yeah you
haven't been yet I've never been to
Europe gay passport yes okay I I like to
make sure you know you never know people
forget things who knows yeah that's it's
okay you don't have to
I I look I I'm a traveler so I like to
make sure people yeah and a carer
yeah that's what it is thank you very
much well Lily this is uh was great
talking to you and I really did like
this a lot I saw this and it's really
well done uh Gilbert godfrey.com
thehidontalent.org or on YouTube uh it's
called the hidden talent of Gilbert
Godfrey and uh you can also go and buy
one of those original art uh uh prints
uh really really great stuff and uh you
should be very proud of you Taylor Swift
man
I didn't go to go to her concert though
why not
uh I don't know
it's a hot ticket well I didn't know did
she try to get tickets and couldn't or
she was just like that no I was just
like okay she went to see cigarettes
after sex yeah
what's that
amazing music because she's cool yeah I
mean she likes the Beatles I can't
question anything else I don't know any
any Taylor Swift to put Troy on too
because he like just found out about a
bunch of her hits four or five years ago
so like I said it's a very late midlife
crisis I don't know I liked a lot of her
old songs I like those too yeah did you
ever hear Set It Off you just shut it
off what's it called Shake It Off oh
sorry yeah Shake It Off
[Laughter]
1989 was a good record right yes yeah
how old do you like to go back with
Taylor Swift uh Teardrops on a guitar
or not quite that old not that old but
uh I Knew You Were Trouble
like I liked her a lot when I was when I
was younger I was a big fan of her when
I was younger and Katy Perry I liked all
the pop music you're kind of maturing
yeah yeah and your tastes are expanding
yeah Troy's going in reverse
before right and now I'm gonna go to
Taylor Swift and you're just reversed
who did you play in the car the other
day it was Coldplay and who are these a
couple of the other ones
um I don't remember
Coldplay butts see Copeland's another
band that we I got a Pink Floyd record
though oh did you like it yeah yeah yeah
Dark Side of the Moon nice yeah one of
the biggest selling albums of all time
good for you it's awesome yeah most
people under the age of 30 don't listen
to anything older like young Coupe there
what did we mention before that young
Coop wasn't familiar with coop is he's
an idiot that's not nice he didn't know
who Dave Grohl was I'd say it wasn't
true he did not and he doesn't know Tom
York is there's no who Dave Grohl is
yeah and he's also I mean he's in he's
in his 20s he's you know yeah he's older
than you but he's
any of it I agree with one of three
that's what I was looking for all right
you go to Gilbert godfrey.com
thehidontalent.org check out this eight
minute short film it's amazing uh and
Lily it's a it's a great accomplishment
so congratulations great job and yeah
congratulations on being uh so composed
at at a very young age it's uh it's
really impressive and it's great thank
you yeah